Hausa Gomez me yeah today I'm here with
she's sick
we are both extremely bad at impressions
so we thought it'd be a great idea to
May so we wrote down 10-year tumors that
we like we're not trying to make
following right here you know we're not
heaters yeah well I am elevating no and
then we wrote down ten random sentences
that we have to read out and impersonate
that person whoever guesses what the
other person impersonates it's a point
most points wins whoever wins is the
best we already know it to me you want
to sorry you said yes
you got my sentence he's gonna be only
one giraffe that he's going to control
the bird is he crying oh my god betray
my move sensual manly voice that I could
have okay you get a point
no I get a point because you did a good
job
fine so you have a point one time I ate
an uncooked bacon and it gave me
diarrhea like that one time I eat
uncooked can't I can't
I move on my turn no sometimes my saliva
tastes like unicorn B so we're one when
I blink fast enough I can see dead
people
yeah now she's not she's cool you know
like cool
every time I dance I take off my bra and
I wear it like a hat okay let me try it
again
every time my name's I think of my beard
wait I like to stare people in this part
and then if all of them home you're
gonna have to do that again I like to
stare people Wheaton Park and then a
colon at home Jack's fails no why did
you keep mouthing off me he has kind of
these boys but bananas are delicious and
nutritious it's funny I thought it you
because you said bananas and everything
all right then
[Music]
and we only had alfie saying make me
travel back in time too bad I never
touched them boobs jet oh my god okay
let me get one which I make me travel
I'm not saying it differently I missing
okay well no point to me I will
jacksFilms real voice sorry I'm not
gonna do my impression three two one
it's an agate howtobasic
my nipples for parents they hurt when I
touch I love broccoli meat ones are the
best I don't know I love broccoli you're
scaring me broccoli are the best
broccoli broccoli is the drop Holly are
you trying to be me that is the worst me
[Music]
I secretly love be in public polls I say
I dropped it in lemonade I don't know
it's really fast
so I guess Ryan Higa date up snot they
don't talk hey there is one boy right
here
fine you win they actually ouch you
don't wait
maybe the comments do you think she'd be
[Laughter]
my sims any needs to take a break hope
you enjoy watching go ahead and lean
like if you did and we'll see you some
other time
PS bra
[Music]